[Music]
In short,
[Music] We
will award the Royal Order to the sugar candy that Jonas Wonder brought.
[Applause] [
Music] We will
show His Majesty the King the Ginza and Santal that the organization has created, and we will present the
sugar candy to His Majesty the King.  [
Music]
What does this mean? The
Ginza party doesn't look exactly like a barrel. It's
such a stupid
love. My husband said that the teacher with Ginza was so
bad that he couldn't
make the required amount, so he was blindsided.  She
sneaked me, who can use magic, into a barrel and made it look like it was full. How
could I show her that she was
looking for His Majesty? The
fairy who ate it is here. She
is a fairy. She made that request just because she wanted to be one of Ginza's comrades.  I
sneaked them into the barrel. These
guys are my friends.